police are trying to determine why an
SUV they believe was carrying a family
of eight just plunged off a cliff in
Northern California Jennifer and Sarah
Hart from Washington State and three of
their children were found dead at the
scene
the other three are still missing at
this hour their son Devante heart became
well-known back in 2014 because of this
picture
showing him hugging a police sergeant at
a protest anne-marie green is here
tracking this investigation anne-marie
it's such a bizarre sad story it really
is still a lot of questions a gal good
morning everyone
a police say that they found the
family's vehicle Monday after a passerby
spotted it at the bottom of the cliff
police don't know what caused the crash
but they believe that all six kids who
were adopted were inside the car and
none of them were wearing their
seatbelts an entire entire family
vanished
Mendocino County Sheriff Tom Allman said
there were no skid or brake marks where
the Hart family's car plunged a hundred
feet off a cliff according to police the
SUV pulled out on a dirt turnout it then
traveled about 75 feet before going over
the cliffs edge and into the Pacific
Ocean police say they are still
searching for 16 year old Hannah 12 year
old Sierra and 15 year old Devante Hart
Devante gained national attention in
2014 when he was photographed hugging a
portland police officer at a protest
those children were blessed and so were
Jenna and Sarah some family friends
describe the hearts as tight-knit but
others noticed problems in 2011 Sarah
Hart pleaded guilty in Minnesota to
domestic assault according to court
records a teacher saw bruises on the
couple's six year-old daughter the girl
told the teacher mom hit me Sarah Hart
allegedly admitted to police she let her
anger get out of control Bruce and Dana
de Cobb who lived next door said they
worried about the kids they portray this
happy little family and yet their
daughters Tonga's please please please
begging is not to make her go back and
that they are abusing her and then
Devante coming over here and telling us
that you know he's being starved to
death Dana Jacobs said she called Child
Protective Services on Friday I was
trying to help
we protect them and this is the result
well neighbors say they saw the family
rush out of their home Friday after CPS
knocked on their door the sheriff said
there's no reason to believe this was
intentional and they'll continue to
investigate and he's asking anyone who
knew the family or their last movements
to come forward again three of the kids
are missing still yeah yeah yeah tragic
Emory thank you